on retrouve véronique prince michel
sauget et christian dufour bon soit en
soi le soir alors depuis que monsieur
legault a lié la survie de la langue
française au québec où rapatriement
complet de tous les pouvoirs en
immigration au québec
elle a bien sûr on allait poser la
question à monsieur trudeau allez-vous
donner au québec les deux sous-ensembles
que vous continuez à contrôler
réunification familiale d'une part et le
programme des réfugiés d'autre part
voici la réponse de monsieur trudeau
la réalité c'est qu'on travaille très
bien en partenariat est depuis longtemps
avec le gouvernement du québec le québec
fait que ses propres cibles au niveau
des migrations c'est sûr que le pays
doit continuer d'avoir un mot à dire sur
son immigration on est très content de
pouvoir partager cette responsabilité
dans le club du terek parce que la
protection du français et de
l'immigration francophone est important
qu'on
dit la poursuivant dans un pays
souverain garde le contrôle d'une partie
en tout cas de l'immigration je vous
montre rapidement tableau qu'on a
préparé hier le québec contrôle le
choisit le gros l'immigration qui vient
avec la fameuse entente que lieu mais le
gouvernement fédéral avec le
regroupement familial douze mille
personnes il est réfugié à peu près 6000
a un rôle à jouer bien sûr alors
véronique prince c'était attendu et là
j'ai envie de vous demander à partir de
là qu'est ce que voir répondre monsieur
legault qu'est ce qu'on fait françois
legault savez très bien que c'est ce que
justin trudeau allait répondre et savait
aussi que ça allait alimenter davantage
le débat que lui-même lancé par ce qu'il
faut comprendre que ça fait un an le cas
des stratèges de son bureau qui ont été
libérés pour préparer la campagne
électorale faut dire que c'est ce que ça
fait avec des élections à date fixe la
met déjà à eux avaient déterminé que le
sujet de la campagne le thème principal
je serai le nationalisme l'identité la
fierté parce que ça génère des émotions
ça fait vibrer la petite corde et quand
on regarde les sondages mais ce qui les
adversaires de monsieur legault à ce
qu'à ce moment là ça pourrait être juste
être doux le gouvernement fédéral parce
que les conservateurs on comprend que
s'ils sont élus peut-être cuir et des
petits anges ou aussi de ce côté là
alors ce que ça pourrait être le
gouvernement fédéral à ce moment là pour
donner une raison aux gens de suivre la
campagne et d'aller voter parce qu'on
peut se poser la question françois
legault veut un mandat fort mais s'il
obtient une centaine de députés mais que
toute participation de 55% à 57 % aux
élections est ce que vraiment il va
avoir un mandat fort alors je pense
qu'en ce moment on décide de préparer de
moussy un peu haut mais en bas on met en
place les personnages le rôle de chacun
l'adversaire et c'est michel serrault
j'ai bon la réponse effectivement de
monsieur trudeau était écrit dans le
ciel
oui d'une part des réfugiés c'est en
vertu d'ententes et internationale que
le canada
ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième des réunifications familiales
dire quelque chose là dedans qui est
aussi de domaine humanitaire quand on
connaît les migrations un peu c'est
souvent une personne seule guérir et qui
quelques années plus tard fait venir sa
femme et ses enfants son époux son
épouse des fois la g à main donc le
gouvernement fédéral veut garder ça mais
dire que il y à un péril en la demeure
si on n'a pas le contrôle la
réunification familiale vous savez la
moitié de ça c'est des enfants qui vont
aller à l'école française en vertu de la
loi 100 je crois sûr que c'est pour mg à
main qui devient la louisiane c'est ce
que je me suis le bon sens ouaip il le
répète aujourd'hui je vous le faire
entendre après mais christian sûr
sur cette déclaration monsieur legault
d'abord en fin de semaine est la réponse
de monsieur trudeau
que je trouve que monsieur legault avait
pas besoin de politiser comme ça aide
aussi à ce point important et dangereux
pour le québec par les deux
louisianisation ça permet un tas de
commentateurs de ridiculiser en fait les
propos de monsieur legault qui était
excessif ya un vrai problème en matière
d'immigration pour
le québec rappelons que le québec est
une des sociétés au monde qui reçoit le
plus d'immigration d'immigrants pourtant
on veut nous présenter comme étant
fermée on ne reçoit plus que les états
unis on ne reçoit plus que la france
perd capita et le problème c'est qu'on
est parti d'un pays qui est dans un
multiculturalisme littéralement délirant
et j'insiste délirant on nous dit qu'on
voudrait recevoir un demi million
d'immigrants paris on nous dit que le
canada devra avoir 100 millions
d'habitants dont le québec c'est clair
que c'est menaçant et puis un autre
élément dans vos tableaux tout à l'heure
et marquer des chiffres importants que
stéphanie grammond par la presse
rappelait ce matin spawn identitaire
tout azimut est ce que ça je t'ai fait
venir à mon elle rappelait qu'en 2019 il
ya soixante et 2000 ils migrent en fait
qui sont ici à titre de résident
temporaire plus que le 40000 normal si
on ajoute en or et en tant que femme
c'est sans voix et si on ajoute les
numéros que sable on nous dit que ça
continue
cette année la majorité des immigrants
au québec soit en train d'utiliser des
voies d'évitement et sans parler sont
des étudiants qui viennent de pays
francophones qui contrairement aux
étudiants qui viennent de pays
anglophones semble sinon bloqué très
très succinct seulement 26 touches
dimanche le logo
d'une seconde revient laissez moi je
regrette beaucoup qu'il est politisé à
ce point là ce dossier là parce que les
analyses tournent toutes autour de
choses passent et plus on sera ça va
être bon pour lui lors de la dernière
campagne électorale
justin trudeau ne pouvait que répondre
ça moi je le répète c'est un aussi
majeur c'est pas un problème artificiel
on est premier dans un pays qui veut
recevoir un demi million d'habitants des
d'immigrants à des puits qui envisagent
d'avoir 100 millions personnes qu'est ce
qu'on fait québec le barreau c'est de ça
dont monsieur legault devrait discuter
avec ottawa de façon rationnelle
traitement parlant de visualisation
alors à la période de questions
aujourd'hui ça rebondit je vous fait
entendre un extrait remet madame anglade
et monsieur
le premier ministre qu'il fait c'est
qu'il divise les québécois il fait tout
pour avoir une chicane avec ottawa
qu'est-ce que je reconnais quand ce
qu'un jour dont je regarde le premier
ministre si on regarde ce qui fait c'est
vraiment un gouvernement qui est en
train de mettre en place une gouvernance
séparatiste on peut s'occuper d'économie
puis en même temps se préoccuper de
l'avenir du français au québec puis
c'est là qu'on voit que le parti libéral
de la difficulté à faire deux choses en
même temps à question que j'ai pour le
premier ministre c'est pourquoi il est
allé par yves survie du québec qui de la
louisiane lorsqu'il parlait de pouvoir
de réunification des familles pourquoi
est allé faire sa une tendance et si on
fait rien à long terme parce que ça
prendra 25 50 60 ans il ya un risque
effectivement que le québec surtout dans
même situation que les autres provinces
canadiennes que la louisiane
donc il l'a véronique il leur rappeler
en fait il le répéter aujourd'hui
cette image de la louisiane pour bien
c'est comme si on est on à entrer dans
les discours là où il faut grossir parce
qu'on a peur de ne pas être entendus
mais c'est parce qu'en fait le débat sur
l'immigration je veux dire ça fait quand
même plusieurs mois le faisais même ans
en 2018 ce débat là durant la campagne
électorale alors c'est comme s'ils
veulent amener plus loin en faisant
référence à la louisiane mais est ce que
vraiment le québec peut comparer sa
situation l'allusion d'ascq en louisiane
ça a réellement été provoqué par des
problèmes de francisation à 10 minutes
selon que je sais pas si vraiment les
deux situations sont sont comparables
mais ce que j'ai remarqué à la période
de questions par contre c'est que
françois legault en quelques pas réussi
son pari parce que c'est sûr qu'en en
ouvrant le front l'immigration comme ça
avec le gouvernement fédéral il prête
flanc pour des attaques du parti libéral
qui veut dire vous voyez un agenda caché
et encore souveraineté c'est encore
séparatiste alors que dans la cac il ya
quand même beaucoup de ministres par
exemple qui sont fédéralistes mais je
pense que je l'aïe est prêt à jouer
parce que de toute façon ses adversaires
en ce moment sont on peut le vent dans
les voiles comme lui et quand j qu'il a
réussi en quelque part son pari c'est
que ça a fait en sorte que pendant la
période de questions depuis trois
semaines dominique anglade sa première
question c'est est toujours sur la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre aujourd'hui ça
a été sur l'immigration on a moins parlé
de santé on a moins parlé crise du
logement on a moins parlé d' inflation
la période de questions parce qu'on
parlait d'immigration on a l'impression
depuis quelques jours michel c'est
christian qu' il y en a qui sont
nostalgiques on aimerait revivre un
épisode d'un côté revenir avec la
barrière s'ouvre à nice fédéralise
monsieur madame anglade et d'autres ont
dit oui très bien vous demain vous
exigez sa d'ottawa si on peut avoir vous
dis non faites quoi est-ce que vous
revenez à vos premières amours et
biologiques la souveraineté est ce que
est ce que tout ce que comment vous
voyez la suite des choses possibles
michèle c'est
le seul endroit où il ya des gens qui
pensent sérieusement que monsieur
legault est un souverainiste caché
depuis quinze jours ils vont ouvrir son
manteau
c'est la communauté anglophone qui est
en train de perdre des appuis d'un
communauté anglophone le parti libéral
et managua enghelab essaie de repartir
cette mayonnaise nord s'est conclu ce
break la mise
alors c'est vous monsieur boulevard
s'ouvre est né sert plus qu'à savourer
de fini alors ça c'est une des choses
l'autre c'est monsieur leubou toujours
eu un problème avec une injection
souvenez vous il se souvenait pas il
savait pas combien ça prenait devenu
citoyen canadien à celle d'avant
toujours sa réunification familiale à
venir des mots nommé matin des cousins
et des cousines
espagne soit quelqu'un qui est habitué
à parler d'immigration à être dans les
communautés immigrantes les pros fait
beaucoup de festivals getty la
communauté tu as bien monsieur legault
ce passe pas sa spécialité ça alors et à
chaque fois qu'il parle des migrations
dirait qu'ils trouvent un moyen d'
exagérés ou de dire des choses qui sont
pas vraies christian vous disiez c'est
important
de parler ouvertement des choix qu'on
veut faire au cours des prochaines
années en immigration en même temps au
québec le débat c'est beaucoup 55 70 70
cinq ans c'est pas des personnes ne
propose de couper le robinet
complètement
non non c'est quand je suis je trouve ça
désolant pour être la façon de ce don ce
dossier est vécue je répète monsieur
legault pas besoin de ça pour se faire
réélire et en tout respect pour rire au
nez que je trouve que lloris eu son pari
de façon très très superficielle de
façon très partisane parce qu'on touche
à quelque chose de très sérieux je le
répète on est pogné dans un pays qui
veut recevoir un demi million
d'habitants par année
au nez de quelqu'un qui sache ouest mais
qui rejoint notre prince cuse et oui oui
oui c'est que la majorité des immigrants
au québec ont tendance à venir par des
voies d'évitement faut en parler ça le
chemin rock simple c'est de moins en
moins mineurs les émirats je me répète
je le sais mais c'est dawson il faudrait
se moderniser les entends québec-ottawa
matière d'immigration s'asseoir avec
justin trudeau pour la provoquer pour
qu'ils disent non c'était sûr qu'en
parlant de visualisation de ce que tu
dirais non on connaît en fait ce cénacle
ensemble c'est trop importante pour
jouer ce jeu là moi ça me déçoit de ce
logo est décrédibilisé le dossier parce
que tout le monde dit louis 6 à 10 ans
aussi ridicule série death que mais il
ya un vrai problème peuvent prendre un
grave problème urgent à très bien je
radote aujourd'hui mais
j'allais être poli je vais pas vous dire
ça mais on passait du parc on passe à
l'upac jo faire entendre l'opposition
qui requit qui revient là aussi on veut
jouer dans un vieux film
l'opposition qui dit ara voilà la preuve
monsieur la première qui est soupçonné
par la police d'avoir lui même orchestré
des pluies la preuve que tout ça est une
police politique qu'avait des caves et
des agendas politiques qui avaient des
guerres de clans cas mais chantant la
position peu enviable
est ce que les banques devront disposer
quand on est rendu à
arrêter déjà le jour d'un budget quand
on est rendu à poser ce genre de geste
là
sont pas un modèle oui je pense qu'on
peut répondre oui à la question si vous
me posez la question si à l'époque c'est
une police politique la réponse est oui
et le fait qu'on a encore des gens qui
étaient là l'époque qui sont là
présentement la lutte avec nous à zik à
croire que rien n'a changé québec
solidaire toujours été critiques sur la
lenteur des actions de l'upac ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui
c'est y avait à l'intérieur
potentiellement l'intérieur des éléments
qui faisait que la paire des
bons rapidement est ce que c'est la fin
à proprement parler de l'upac oui on
parle du passé mais quand même c'est le
même corps policiers véronique michel et
christian moi je verrai difficilement
est la ministre guilbaud dissoudre un
corps policier comme comme l'upac là je
veux dire l'upac et elle est censée être
indépendante du politique
geneviève guilbault une patate chaude
entre les mains là pourraient pas
dissoudre un corps policier comme ça je
penserai paul et surtout qui a été le
nouveau patron était lui aux deux tiers
l'assemblée nationale michèle
le problème du pain qu'actuellement
c'est que quand on parle de l'upac on
entend le bruit des casseroles qu'ils
traînent et ça c'est très fatigant parce
que ça confort tous les gens qui ont des
doutes envers du pack est ce que c'est
une police politique ou pas je ne sais
pas mais le monsieur la première faisait
de la politique toute évidence ça ça va
pas s'en aller alors est ce que tu peux
encore à cause de toutes ces casseroles
lac ils prêts moi je commence à penser
que non mais je demande d'être on récuse
contre un et je rappelle une crise âge
donne la parole mais je rappelle que ça
fait presque 4 1
4 1 qu'on enquête sur les fuites à
l'upac on se dit ah pas de 1 million de
personnes qui travaillent là comment ça
peut être si compliqué mais ça doit être
compliqué manifestement mais d'arriver à
une conclusion alors les gens en perdent
leur latin et un christian web on ne
salit beaucoup de réputation
je pense qu'il ya plus grand bond au
québec qui fait confiance du bac je sais
pas si on peut dissoudre l'organisation
ou pas mais j'aimerais ça qu'on puisse
sous de cette organisation parce que son
bras dos était de rétablir la confiance
dans les actions publiques moi j'ai plus
de respect quelques pas pour un gangster
qui fait sa job le gagne ça parce que
notre entité vous êtes en faut 15 ans
déjà qu'ils sont nommés lol pour
rétablir la confiance tout indique
qu'ils ont pas respecter leur serment
d'office
comment voulez vous qu'on croit à cette
gagnante je sais que c'était injuste
pour les nouveaux mais moi ce que je
souhaite au nouveau qu'ils fassent un
coup d'éclat incontestable merveilleux
parce que sinon l'upac mois quand on
peint de l'upac jeu même pas lire
l'article ça m'intéresse pas au père
christian son nom mais il faut que vous
lisiez l'article aveyronnais
comprenez ce que je veux cette année pas
question de donner maintenant j'ai
compris mais madame guilbaud en vrai
c'est très court en victime du bo la
réponse qui dix ans plus que vous dès
demain pour vous que ça mais peut pas
dissoudre tout de suite un coup de main
à guilbeault c'est pas des choses qui
sont du jour au lendemain ces
changements organisationnels important
monsieur elle est comme ça on a mis deux
ans et demi deux ans donc il est en
fonction leur moi on laisse la chance
mais c'est sûr que là partir du moment
où on leur donner tous les outils
législatifs réglementaires on a mis un
nouveau comme ça donc c'est à eux de
livrer la marchandise et de faire le
travail qu'ils sont à femmes on a
confiance
vivement une enquête bien bouclé avec
des accusations qui vont tenir michel un
peu seuls
si tant est qu'on puisse le trouver mais
il y avait juste une phrase de trop dans
ce que madame les deux bouts odyssée
j'ai confiance je pense que le
gouvernement convient au sein du pack
actuellement je fais ce qu'on n'est pas
en train d'attendre après des élections
pour faire le travail qu'on peut pas
faire avant l'élection parce que comme
je dise un pic est certain c'est un peu
comme moi il n'y a pas grand monde qui
croient qu'il est dans une course parce
qu'on ne perdez pas pourquoi on dissout
pas un départ pourtant il dissout pas
dis pas que personne qui croit sommes
maintenant presque sûrs et croisé
est ce que on va savoir les fouette un
jour cette enquête du béryl scav aboutir
un jour on se pose tous la question
effectivement et je pense qu'elle laisse
frédéric gaudreau jusqu'en 2024 parce
que le dimanche j'ai besoin de trois ans
faire mon travail c'est jusqu'à trois
ans ça peut passer vite là moi j'ai
besoin de dix secondes parce qu'on part
merci beaucoup à vous trois bonnes sur
travail et hors droits soit
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit